Yesterday was a truly historic day.
Donald Trump has become the third president
in the history of the United States to be
impeached, and this came at the conclusion
of really almost 12 hours of proceedings in
the house of representatives, including eight
hours of debate.
The house of representatives impeach the president
of the United States on two articles.
Article one is abuse of power.
Article two is obstruction of Congress.
Now, there are both Republicans and some Democrats
who are pretending that this is no big deal
or they are skipping to, he's going to be
acquitted in the Senate and not removed.
Therefore, this entire thing was a waste of
time.
That couldn't be the more, you couldn't find
a more incorrect place to start our analysis
of what took place yesterday.
So let's actually talk through it because
this is huge news.
Only two presidents before Donald Trump have
ever been impeached, one in the 19th century
and another in the 20th century.
And now we have Donald Trump, president number
three in the 21st century.
This is very rare.
Andrew Johnson was impeached in 1868 was impeached
on 11 articles including violating the tenure
of office act and Andrew Johnson was acquitted
in the eventual impeachment trial.
Go to the 20th century.
In 1998, bill Clinton was impeached for lying
under oath and for obstruction of justice
related to a sexual harassment lawsuit that
was filed against him by Paula Jones and related,
uh, to, uh, bill Clinton's testimony denying
a relationship he had had with white house
intern, Monica Lewinsky.
Bill Clinton was also acquitted in the Senate
impeachment trial.
Now, Richard Nixon was not impeached in the
1970s he would have been and likely would
have been convicted.
But knowing this, knowing that the Republican
public had turned against Richard Nixon, knowing
that Republicans in the Senate could no longer
stand by Richard Nixon knowing he would be
impeached and convicted.
He resigned on August 9th, 1974.
An iconic moment in American political history.
Quick reminder of that
on the great issue with peace abroad and prosperity
without inflation at home.
Therefore, I shall resign the presidency effective
at noon tomorrow.
Vice president Ford will be sworn in as president
at that hour.
So
a huge, huge deal.
Even Nixon was not impeached but resigned.
Let's go to video from yesterday.
Last night, uh, we were streaming at the time,
I think it must've been about eight, 8:15
PM Eastern time, a video from the house of
representatives, speaker of the house, Nancy
Pelosi announcing the impeachment.
You will also, if you're watching notice her
visibly quiet, the applause and cheering that
broke out from the democratic side, clearly
wanting, uh, not to make this seem like something
you would cheer about because it is very serious
quite frankly.
Here she is announcing article number one
impeachment of Donald Trump on this vote.
The yeas are 230.
The nays are one 97 present is one article,
one is adopted.
The question is aren't adoption of articles.
And then very shortly thereafter, after a
five minute plus, a couple extra minute vote
on article two, obstruction of Congress, Nancy
Pelosi speaker of the house announcing that
Donald Trump has also been impeached on article
number two
on this vote.
The A's are 229 the nays are one 98.
Present is one.
Article two is adopted.
The votes were all most almost along party
lines.
230 in total voting for impeachment on article
one because of vacancies in the house.
Instead of two 18 to impeach, they needed
only two 16.
They got two 30 on article two, uh, almost
the same numbers, 229 voting to impeach one
former Republican who is now an independent
Justin Amash voted to impeach on both counts.
You then had two Democrats, Collin Peterson
of Minnesota who some know of as a dyno Democrat
in name only, Colin Peterson of Minnesota,
not voting to impeach Jefferson van drew of
New Jersey voting not to impeach.
And van drew is um, this member who's made
headlines over the last few days.
He's expected to switch from being a Democrat
to a Republican very, very soon.
And then you had Jared golden of Maine who
split his vote saying yes on article one no
on article two.
And that's why there were 230 votes in favor
on article one.
Uh, only 229 votes in favor on article two.
Then you had a one individual who voted present
and that was, um, there's this Hawaii Congress
woman she's running, um, technically running
for president, uh, Tulsi Gabard who is not
seeking reelection for her seat.
She took no position voting merely present
on both articles.
She said, quote, I could not in good conscience
vote against impeachment because I believe
Donald Trump is guilty of wrongdoing.
I also could not in good conscience vote for
impeachment because removal of a sitting president
must not be the culmination of a partisan
process.
Now what's complete nonsense about that is
that there's never an even split in Congress
between the parties.
So by definition you have 435, it's an odd
number.
It's always a partisan process in the sense
that it's led by one party.
Uh, and by that logic, she could never vote
to impeach anyone.
Now, I guess what she's saying is she would've
preferred the process, involve more Republicans,
but that's a completely unrealistic expectation
in the hyper-partisan Fox news era of politics.
I don't want to waste too much time on Tulsi
Gabard.
Who cares what she does?
Okay.
She decided to just ride the middle.
I do think it is yet another signal that she
may be planning a third party run for president,
which could have its own series of implications.
She'll be gone for the house in January.
Okay.
I don't think I need to say too much more
about that.
Now, here is Trump.
I'm talking back in 2008 with Wolf Blitzer.
You know what took place yesterday was a big
deal.
It was carried out by serious people, Nancy
Pelosi speaker of the house.
You had uh, uh, um, uh, Adam Schiff in the
house intelligence committee.
You had Jerry Nadler in the house judiciary
committee.
These are serious people doing serious work.
Here's video of Donald Trump.
Back in 2008 telling Wolf Blitzer, he finds
Nancy Pelosi impressive and would like to
have seen her actually do more on impeachment
in times past.
This is a classic video instantly.
Nancy Pelosi, the speaker, well, you know
when she first got in and was named speaker,
I met her and I'm very impressed by her.
I think she's a very impressive person.
I like her a lot, but I was surprised that
she didn't do more in terms of Bush and going
after Bush.
It was almost, it just seemed like she was
going to really look to impeach Bush and get
him out of office, which personally I think
would have been a wonderful thing for the
war, for the war because of the conduct.
We lied.
He got us into the war with lies and I mean,
look at the trouble bill Clinton got into
with something that was totally unimportant
and they tried to impeach him, which was nonsense.
And yet Bush got us into this horrible war
with lies by lying, by saying they had weapons
of mass destruction by saying all sorts of
things that turned out not to be true.
So
Nancy Pelosi has done it and this is already
significant no matter what anybody tells you,
this is a huge deal.
This is a historic day.
Now let's talk about the next step.
The next step is a trial in the Senate without
regard to the likely outcome of the Senate
trial.
Impeachment is a serious constitutional responsibility
given to the house and Senate and the house
did its job.
And I know that there are lots of people and
they're emailing me and tweeting me saying,
Trump's going to be acquitted in the Senate.
This is all a waste of time.
The house is the, it has a role to play in
this process and it is to determine whether
articles of impeachment are appropriate.
They did their job.
Now I agree with you.
The most likely outcome of the trial in the
Senate is Trump being acquitted because Republicans
control the Senate and we'll go through the
math in a moment.
But you sometimes just have to do the right
thing because it's the right thing to do,
even if it won't have the immediate effect
that you might want.
Imagine not doing this and then Trump gets
himself reelected and then in five or 10 years
you realize why, why didn't I vote to impeach?
It was the right thing to do.
It might have prevented Trump from getting
reelected, although it might not.
Uh Oh right.
We calculated we were going to lose in the
Senate.
No, that's not how we do things.
Trump has been daring anyone to hold them
accountable and he's basically not been held
accountable.
He has now been impeached and is one of only
three presidents in history to have suffered
that fate.
It's the right step, even if he is not going
to be convicted in the Senate.
So let's now get to the analysis of the Senate.
Is it possible that Donald Trump will be convicted
in the Senate?
Sure.
It's possible.
The math is you need two third support.
There's a hundred senators.
Two thirds is 66 and two thirds, meaning 67
senators need to vote to convict.
In order for the president to be removed.
We have 45 Democrats in the Senate.
There are two independence, Bernie Sanders
and Angus King who caucus with the Democrats.
That's like 47 votes probably for conviction.
Joe mansion.
The most conservative democratic Senator,
uh, might not vote to convict.
We don't know.
But for our purposes today, let's assume we
have 47 votes in the Senate.
That means you need 20 Republicans.
Uh, Chris Murphy, a Senator from Connecticut
says he thinks that there's about five Republican
senators that would consider voting, uh, for
conviction.
Uh, bill weld, former Republican governor
here in Massachusetts who's running a pretty
flimsy, uh, campaign, but a campaign nonetheless,
a primary campaign against Donald Trump.
Bill weld says he thinks there's about five
Republicans that would consider voting to
convict.
That won't be enough.
Even if that's true, it won't be enough.
So is it likely that Trump will be convicted,
convicted?
Absolutely not.
The Republican public and voters don't want
it.
Republican senators I don't think would even
really consider it unfortunately unless the
electorate wanted it because it would be too
politically disadvantageous or at least potentially
risky.
Um, but the idea would be if Chris Murphy
and bill weld are correct, if there are a
handful of Republicans willing to vote for
conviction, maybe that would spread like a
virus and if you know, I don't think it's
going to happen, but if they decided that
there would be a secret ballot where it wouldn't
be known which senators vote, which way you
might be able to enough momentum where you
get 20 Republicans that say let's convict.
I think it is very unlikely.
If I had to handicap it, I would say it's
a roughly two to 4% chance that something
like that happens.
What are the logistics of the trial?
Number one, when will the trial be?
It's unclear because it was presumably going
to be in January upon the return from holiday
break.
But we have just heard from Nancy Pelosi and
we'll deal with this story in full later on
in the program, that she is going to withhold
the articles from the Senate until such time
that she believes there will be what she considers
to be a fair hearing and a fair trial.
That may never happen, but uh, the January
date is now certainly a question Mark.
How long will the impeachment trial last?
We don't know.
It would generally be expected to run somewhere
between two and four weeks.
Will it be televised?
I don't know.
Um, I did a bunch of research on this today
and there is no hard and fast rule about what
has to happen.
It would be part of the negotiations that,
um, the house leadership would have with Senate
leadership as they move articles of impeachment
in that direction.
Now, unfortunately, Donald Trump will also
get a say because Mitch McConnell, the Senate
majority leader has already said he will be
in total coordination with the white house
about how the impeachment trial will be carried
out.
That's not good.
Uh, will this help Trump win in 2020?
That is the major political question.
If Trump is convicted, he's out and he will
not be reelected.
Of course, if Trump is acquitted, there are
two ways that it could go.
One is his acquittal is successfully used
as look at this witch hunt.
I am a martyr.
I am the most unfairly treated president in
history, which he's been tweeting about and
we'll get to later and it reinvigorates his
supporters, uh, and increases right-wing voter
turnout and rockets him to reelection.
That is a plausible, and I would say even
realistic political risk to this process.
The other would be if the timing and the setup
of impeachment, uh, it gets delayed a little
bit.
So it starts overlapping with when we start
getting into the general election, maybe over
the summer, hypothetically, if it is televised,
if Trump is constantly going crazy publicly,
if it becomes subject matter of the debates
between Donald Trump and the eventual democratic
nominee, it could certainly end up hurting
him.
It's a question Mark, but there are major
political risks with this doesn't change that
it's the right thing to do.
Lastly, would there be violence if Donald
Trump were convicted and removed?
Uh, I believe that there would they, uh, on
the right, the Trump has to have been throwing
around terms like a civil war picking sides.
And uh, well, you know, we also heard from
that crazy pastor Rick Wiles who says that
this is a Juku to remove Donald Trump and
eventually the military will have to pick
a side.
I sadly believe there will be violence if
Donald Trump were to be convicted on an, on
impeachment.
And by the way, I think it's also quite plausible
that there will be violence if Donald Trump
loses the 2020 election.
But asserts that he didn't really lose that
it was stolen from him in some way.
I fear violence over the next year and I,
I hate to admit that, uh, let me know what
you think about the house vote, the Senate
trial.
We'll get to a lot of these sub stories including
holding the articles of impeachment for a
while, uh, before giving them over to the
Senate in the next few segments.
Remember that on January 1st we will have
a, a, an amazing 2020 kickoff membership fund
drive.
And if you have been thinking about supporting
the show, I would particularly encourage you
to do it in an election year, which is typically
when these shows grow the most and get the
most attention.
Uh, consider getting on our mailing list that
David pakman.com sign up for our newsletter.
And then in, uh, January 1st, 2020, you'll
get an email with instructions on how to
sign up at an obscene, sickening, disgusting
discount.
You will be disgusted at how big the discount
is, but your credit and debit cards will be
very pleased with you.
Quick break.
We'll be right back after that.